hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game it's from round nine of
the Croatian Grantchester being played
in Zagreb shot here mama da reverses
Vishwanathan Anand we do have one photo
of this matchup here it is courtesy of
Lennart oldest official photographer of
the Grantchester and as a bonus question
for you who is the gentleman making the
first move
for for Shaw now that being said let's
check out this very nice game it's
already round line there are 11 rounds
so the tournament is you know nearing
its end and it's well still still very
it can be anyone's tournament so let's
just check it out mama DRF opens with d4
with Knight to f6 c4 sorry about that
now with a 6 from Anand Knight to f3 and
of course you don't know what what we're
gonna see we have d5 the Queens gambit
declined nice to see 3 and now D
captures on c4 and E for a line in mama
D are of place very often with Bishop to
b4 now Bishop captures on c4 and now we
have Knight captures on e4 and here we
have just castles by mama D ro and here
although it seems like you can win
material here it's not all that simple
for example if you try something like
Knight captures pawn captures and Bishop
captures then white might even try
something like Bishop day 3 says okay
you can have my rook I will gladly give
you my rook for a very strong dark
square Bishop I'm gonna prevent you from
castling and it's gonna be very awkward
playing this position with black on the
other hand you could try Bishop
characters on c3 it seems to work work
out very nicely after pawn captures
Knight chapters now the Queen is under
attack let's say queen bee 390 d5 but it
doesn't helped because if you want to
castle the safety with black I mean if
you don't want to allow Bishop to e3
you're gonna have to Castle very quickly
because after rook to e1 you're again
threatening to win material here would
Bishop capture since you will not be
able to recapture with the pawn and here
after you Castle you're just gonna get
Bishop to a three just a nice developing
move rook to e8 and now after Bishop
captures on d5
you will play ECAP force on d5 and queen
characters on d5
winds back the pond so in fact you will
not be winning any points of course you
cannot capture because your captors any
eight will be made and even if you trade
once it's even worse because now black
is just lost you don't really have a
good move whatever you play but should
be seven rookie seven let's say it's
coming bishop nicely guards the rook
there and you cannot defend against both
threats of rope captures here and Queen
captures on f7 fall by Queen captures
and g7 mate so although it seems like
you can win material you really can't so
night back to f6 by Anand and now Queen
to a pork check check and you're
threatening to win the bishop so knight
c6 this is the only move and here
mama are already had this position for
example against Quran and Bundesliga
this year where he played Knights the e5
but here he goes for Bishop to g5 a move
mama D off played against the young
shift of Duda in the TAT of steel I just
tournament at the beginning of the year
with Bishop captures and c3 the same as
in game mama reverses do the B captures
on c3 with castles by black and now
comes Luke F the e1 rook F the e1 is a
new move in the game against Duda
muhammediye I've tried again nice e5 but
here looked after a one is a new move so
let's see how unearned the deals with a
completely new game so first night the
Knights the e7 he wants to remain over
this night over to over to f5 from there
and the night will guarded the h4 square
and then Anand wants to play h4 h 6
where the bishop will not be able to
retreat the h4 and here the bishop will
be forced to either retreat back or to
capture on f6 and you don't want to
capture on f6 if you don't really have
to since you don't want to give up your
bishop prepare for nothing
so here although you could do it you
don't really want to do it Bishop to d3
by Mahmoud er off and now the bishops
are very nicely attacking the black king
now for example if this Queen was over
here it would already be a very nice
attacking position but it's not all that
easy to bring the Queen over there with
an eye to the f5 by Anand and now comes
Luke 8 to d1 a very important move as
like we said on this planning planning
h6 so he plays it and now Bishop back to
c1 and now if your roof was still on a1
your rooks would you know and not be
connected so this way the rook is nicely
placed on and on a D file and now
everything is alright for for white with
b6 by Anand preparing Bishop to b-17
cattle the LightSquared bishop and now
see for a very nice move by mommy Europe
now but should be 7:10 at some in some
cases be met with d5 because if the
bishop is no longer and this diagonal
the knight is unprotected so you will
not be able to capture with the pawn at
the point is needed for the protection
of the night we have rook to e8 first by
Anand and now Bishop to b2 and ice
developing move by Mahmoud off and now
Bishop to b7 and here you have to really
decide whether whether or not to pull d5
once you push it you can't on push it I
mean it looks really great black cannot
capture as the knight would hang you
open up this beautiful diagonal for your
dark square Bishop problem is after
night the b6
yes you can capture on e6 but black and
play Bishop captures on f3 and after it
captures on f7 check Knight captures you
will get rook captures here Queen
captures Queen captures captures on e8
and then G captures on f3 and here you
would have this position where you have
two bishops against two nights but the
rooks are still on the board and well
black's pawn structure is just much
better Black has dewpoint islands
whereas White has a four point islands
and also the D doubled F pawn so black
is definitely to be preferred here so
you don't really gain anything by
pushing d5 right away
so first mama D improves Knight to e5
it's an excellent outpost for the night
and now Knight to e7 by Anand with
Russia back the b1 a standard attacking
idea and you want to talk talk your
mushrooms back and now leave them here
there are just beautiful attacking
pieces and now c5 by islands just
attacking the strong center so now while
you can capture on c5 here and it comes
with an attack on the Queen after Queen
to c7 you can capture even an outer pawn
and now you've equalized in points as
black was already up upon but you've
given black really a lot of activity so
first I don't go origami arrow goes
Queen to c2 brings the Queen over to
this beautiful diagonal aligns it with
the h7 Square and now prepares to go for
and for a very nice attack we have Queen
the c7 by Anand knock on
d captures on c5 and now under doesn't
butter which recapturing but first rook
a to d8 he just wants to mobilize his
pieces as quickly as possible with
Caterson b6 captures on b6 and now
finally mama dev starts the attack
Knight to g4 and here you have to ask
yourselves how do you prevent this
attack of course if you capture the
night its Queen h7 check King f8 and
queen or virtual captors on g7 will be
made so how do you prevent the attack if
you try well feel free to pause the
video and try to figure out the best
defensive move for Anand in this
position I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent defensive player and for those
you who just won't enjoy the show the
movies well first let's try Knight g6
what happens if Knight g6 then you just
for example capture here and well you
you lose the exchange here as it's check
you're gonna lose the row Kanye so what
Anand played is Knight to e4 and it's
it's really a nice move because you have
to see that Mama DRF has a lot of
background weaknesses for example and
now it seems like you can capture the
night here but not really because after
loop captures Bishop captures on e4 will
be deadly the queen is under attack for
example if you capture rogue captures
here will be made on the other hand
after this Knight to e4 move if you try
to trade once first let's say rook
captures and e8 rook after sandy 8 and
only now recap for Sonny for it's pretty
much the same Bishop captures on e4 and
okay now you can move the Queen let's
say Quincy won but now you get Queen to
f4 and now again you try to exploit a
white background weaknesses if the queen
is captured then rogue d1 will be made
so after you make some room for your
King let's say f3
I black will just win material Queen
captures Bishop captures and Bishop
captures here and your also comes with a
lot of threats Ruby 1 is a threat so a
completely winning position so after
this Knight d4 move of course mom your
cannot capture it he plays f3 now forces
the Knights to move but now Anand has
Queen c5 check with King to h1 and now
you cannot go on I have to check because
this Knight is guarding the f2 square so
first mama door pushes 8
sorry Anand pushes age five he wants to
kick the night away and then play night
if to check and win material it's you
know very very nicely done but my Madero
goes night h6 check as he will win this
night so at least he wants the Miss
opponent's pawn structure on and half
the capture will G captors on h6f
captures on e4 but now Annan pushes a
five and here with this if I move on and
completely closes of this diagonal so he
doesn't have to worry about it anymore
or does he because here mama Dara of
plays rook to d5 and rook to d5 is just
an ugly move it says I'm prepared to
give up some material to release my
bishop pair and you don't really have an
option of declining this if you move the
Queen then just rook captures on e5 and
next after we capture pawn you're just
gonna move the rook back to wherever
probably capture the h5 point you're
gonna then be able to push this pawn and
release the bishop that way so on and
says okay I I do have to accept your
your offer but I'm not gonna accept it
with the night if I play Knight captures
after this there is a really no
preventing a queen to h7 so instead on
and plays Bishop captures on d5 with he
captures on d5 now this diagonal is once
again open but now Knight to g6 just
closing it once again we've looked F and
now what do you play here as soon as I
saw this position eyes I thought well
the whites biggest compensation for for
the exchange is the beautiful d5 pawn
also the bishop pair is very nice but
this is the real strength in the
position so I thought why not b5 just
try and undermine it it seems very nice
well it takes a lot of calculating to do
because he rook captures on f7 is the
idea of course if you capture you lose
the game because Queen captures on g6
but after rook to d6
black black should be okay but Anand
finds a different idea first Ottoman
plays rook to e7 which is not all that
great
in the case that I've shown b5 was
better because here if white wants white
white can pretty much force a draw after
rook captures on f7 now capture screen
captures and g6 would check King to f8
and now Queen captures and h6 with check
King e7 you can go Queen b6 check King
goes back
here Queen check King goes here Queen
checks here and you have a forced fourth
draw by repetition so b5 was a bit
better than this rook to e7 move but now
Madeira is not interested in a draw he
goes Queen to see one threatens to win
dh6 pawn and now rook to a seven by
Anand I don't really have a good
explanation on rook to a7 or why was
played it seems like a very strange move
to me I'm sure it has its reasons
although it's it's very hard to pinpoint
them and maybe I don't know maybe the
idea is bring the other rook over to
somehow defend DF 7 point and then maybe
play rock a4 and go after the e4 pawn
which is really the base of the strong
function in white Center but other than
that a really really strange move
although maybe I'm just blind so if any
of you have an idea do share in the
comments but okay here we don't have
Queen captures on h6 right away because
then black can actually capture on c4
and after rook captures on f7 rook
captures on f7 Queen captures in g6 you
get rook g7 and then again Queen e6
check you're gonna go King h8 and and so
on and so on
so first mama drf plays h3 like we've
shown here after this Queen to e6 check
you you can't really play something like
Bishop captures here as a queen to f1
would be checkmate so here in before
going for something like Queen captures
on h6 mama daughter plays h3 he makes
some room for the king so in the line
that we've just shown Queen to f1 will
not be made and now rook the d6 Ana
brings another defender to the King side
with Queen captures on h6 and now Luke
back to e7 so it's very interesting what
this group was actually doing on a 7 you
can't capture and see for now because
the rook to see one will just be winning
for white rook c8 it will be deadly so
Luke goes back to e 7 which does seem
like the square where the rook belongs
now Queen back to c1 and with this move
Mamiya of threatens bush up to a3 to
really connect here nicely and finally
Anand pushes b5 but now if you don't
want to lose the
well very strong pawn chain you have to
play Bishop to e3 this mama what mama D
ro does with me for now Bishop to b2 and
now look the a6 so so what do you play
here here mama Dell goes for rook to f5
he goes after the h5 pawn and now comes
f6 by an injustice strengthening the e5
pawn here now is this one of the cases
where it's actually okay to play f6 well
we'll just have to wait and see
mama yard goes Queen to h6 now as by
playing f6 the night here is no longer
defended and what do you play here how
do you defend the night feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
defensive move for Anand I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
found Knight to f4 congratulations
it's the move Anand played but it's not
the best move it's actually well it's
not even a good move here
rook the g7 is best just defending the
knight with the rook and everything is
fine but here I don't play Knight to f4
and it just doesn't work because here
well once again feel free to pause the
video and try to find why it why Knight
to f4 doesn't work for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent
well sacrificer of bishops and for those
of you just wanna enjoy the show Bishop
captures an e5 is what Mahmud or played
here by playing Knight to f4 Anand
basically saw that if rook captures rook
captures and Queen captures that
everything is the right
he can play Queen captures on c4 and
there's no problem the threat is Queen
to f1 fall by sorry we followed by Queen
to G to checkmate
for example if we capture then it's game
over for Mama dr but what he missed was
actually after Knight to f4 this Bishop
captures on e5 move and now if you
capture the bishop with the pawn you
don't capture the Rho kinase six but you
deliver mate a crook to f8 is checkmate
so after this Bishop captures an e5 move
Anand has to play Queen to f2 it's the
only way threatened checkmate and after
Queen captures on f4 removing the night
now you play Queen to e1 check King to
h2 and now rook captures on e5 rook
captures on f6 rook captures Queen
captures and now you're going to go h4
and with the threat of Queen to g3 you
have an inch
to draw white we'll have to settle for a
perpetual as there is no good way to
bring the bishop into the attack Queen
g6 checking a faith Queen of six
checking eg eight and so on but here
aren't actually played rukka captures on
e5 but this doesn't work
mommy Gaurav just played rook captures
on e5 we have pawn captures on e5 and
now the a6 rook is unguarded Queen
captures on a6 we have Queen to f2 and
it seems like it's the same Anand will
either checkmate Mahmud are off or for
Mom Yara will somehow have to fight
really hard for a draw but it's really
not not the case because mama D ro has
Quinta ch-check King to f7 and now Queen
to f5 check we have King back to g8 and
now Queen to g5 check and with this
check the Queen now guards the aji to
square black again has to waste a move
with King to f8 and now the final touch
in the defense King to h2 not allowing
any any checks to pick up the bishop
here on b1 so as you don't have any
checks here Anand plays h4 it seems like
again you have enough resources for a
draw here but you really don't hear my
mayara played Bishop to f5 and believe
it or not it was in this position that
we found and resigned the game as now
he's just down too much material and he
doesn't have any good ways of continuing
this fight he doesn't have any tricks
for example you can push efore the
bishop will just win that pawn if you
try something like well it's hard to say
what can you even try a knight cat for
some g2 with the idea that if Queen
captures you can capture the bishop here
just Queen f6 check and now the King has
to go to a light Square and you're you
laundry or Queen let's say King g8
Bishop e6 check you have to move and not
just Queen captures on f2 so very nicely
done and on the other hand if you just
try a slow move like Queen III and then
try to get your knight into the game
somehow or something like that
d6 there's really no stopping d7 and d8
and well if you try if you try and go
for the endgame like we said black is
just down too much material for example
Queen captures captures captures
you're gonna go King to e7 and then just
King to f3 and you have too much too
much points it's 5 to 2 there's no you
know it's not even not even close that
white can black and even try to play
this so unnoticed after Bishop to a5 he
resigned and well a much-needed point
for Mama DRF who's been having a
terrible tournament and I thought that
the pod above the board is fitting for
this game that that's what chess is all
about one day you give your opponent to
listen to the next day he gives you one
as mama really received a lot of lessons
this tournament so here he gave one I
want one a tournament
so just the way chess is and also we
said that we were gonna check out the
standings so here they are this is the
only decisive game from round nine all
the other games ended in a draw but even
but they were really fighting games
really who's saying games especially for
example nipple versus Wesley so nipple
was dead lost but somehow again he
managed to draw the game it was just
well just insane
Magnus still first clear first with six
and a half but Wesley really close with
six so only half a point behind Magnus
and they faced each other today in round
10 so it's gonna be really really
awesome Wesley has the white pieces
against Magnus then with five points
Fabiana karana yeah upon xi and xi onion
with four and a half ding leerin Maxine
was sherrilyn Grove onigiri and Sarah
Kerrigan would for a shocker Moroccan
Vishwanath along with three and a half
and he Cara Nakamura in last place with
three points but still two more runs to
go he can he can definitely improve on
that yeah
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Hanson Rodriguez
teal sheis McHale Gebhardt
rich Piper and Tobias Mishima for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon I'm probably going to visit the
the Grantchester once again today I'm
gonna try and get my two signatures that
are missing from my board to me you know
make it a nice complete signed chess
board but we'll see how it goes you know
you you know you can never know how
these things will go so once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I will see soon and
have an excellent rest of your day